LADY, A WOMAN WHO SAYS SHE
HELPED RAISE HIM.
THEY LOOK LIKE ANY OTHER COUPLE
WALKING IN CENTRAL PARK, THROUGH
TIMES SQUARE.
TONIGHT "THE WASHINGTON POST"
SAYS FOR NEARLY 20 YEARS THIS
HUSBAND AND WIFE KEPT THEIR TRUE
IDENTITIES HIDDEN.
THE QUIET OWNERS OF A SMALL DRY
CLEANING STORE SAY THEY'RE THE
AUNT AND UNCLE OF ONE OF THE
WORLD'S MOST NOTORIOUS
DICTATORS, NORTH KOREA'S KIM
JONG-UN.
>> THEY LIVE A REMARKABLE
AMERICAN IMMIGRANT LIFE.
>> Reporter: HER AUNT IS THE
SISTER OF HIS MOTHER.
>> SHE'S SOMEONE THAT SHE WOULD
TRUST, YOU KNOW, OBVIOUSLY WITH
THE LIVES OF HER CHILDREN.
>> Reporter: SHE TOLD THE POST
SHE TRAVELED FROM NORTH KOREA TO
TAKE CARE OF KIM, HIS OLDER
BROTHER AND YOUNGER SISTER WHEN
THEY ATTENDED THIS BOARDING
SCHOOL IN SWITZERLAND.
>> HE WAS NOT A GOOD STUDENT.
HE DID NOT ENJOY STUDYING.
>> Reporter: POST REPORTER
INTERVIEWED HER AND HER HUSBAND
AFTER UNCOVERING THEIR EXISTENCE
THROUGH A LAWSUIT THEY FILED.
THE LOCATION OF THE DRY CLEANING
BUSINESS AND THEIR HOME NOT
BEING REVEALED.
THEY TELL THE STORY OF A YOUNG
MAN THAT WAS PRIVILEGED AND KNEW
HE WOULD INHERIT THE LEADERSHIP
OF NORTH KOREA.
SHE TOOK THEM TO EURO DISNEY, TO
THE RIVIERA, OBSESSED WITH
BASKETBALL, THAT HE WOULD SLEEP
WITH A BALL UNDER HIS ARM AND AN
OBSESSION THAT LEAD TO REAL
MOMENTS WITH DENNIS RODMAN.
THERE WAS ONE DAY A CLEAR SIGNAL
WAS SENT THAT YOUNG KIM WOULD
SUCCEED HIS FATHER, HIS 8th
BIRTHDAY.
>> THERE WAS A BIG PARTY AND HE
WAS PRESENTED WITH A GENERAL'S
ARMY UNIFORM THAT DAY AND THERE
WERE REAL GENERALS AT THE PARTY
WHO THEN BOWED TO THE
EIGHT-YEAR-OLD KID.
>> Reporter: FROM THAT MOMENT
SHE SAYS HIS BEHAVIOR CHANGED.
HE WAS SHORT TEMPERED, HAD A
LACK OF TOLERANCE.
>> PRONE TO HAVING TANTRUMS, GET
IN A HUFF ABOUT THINGS.
WHEN HIS MOTHER VISITED AND TOLD
HIM HE SHOULDN'T BE SPENDING SO
MUCH TIME PLAYING BASKETBALL,
THAT HE SHOULD BE STUDYING, HE
WASN'T HAPPY ABOUT THAT, WOULD
GO ON HUNGER STRIKE IS WHAT HIS
AUNT SAID.
>> Reporter: SHE TOLD THE POST
IN 1998 THEY SOUGHT ASYLUM AT
THE U.S. EMBASSY IN SWITZERLAND,
THEN TAKEN TO AN AMERICAN
MILITARY BASE, QUESTIONED FOR
MONTHS.
WHEN THEY GOT TO AMERICA, THEY
RECEIVED MONEY AND FOR A SHORT
TIME HOUSING FROM THE CIA.
THE CIA WOULD NOT COMMENT ON THE
INTERVIEW WITH "THE WASHINGTON
POST."
HER HUSBAND SAYS HE WANTS TO GO
BACK TO PYONGYANG FOR A VISIT,
GOODWILL AMBASSADOR BETWEEN THE
U.S. AND NORTH KOREA.
ONE ANALYST SAYS THAT WOULD BE
A, QUOTE, SUICIDAL ACT.
SHE'S TRYING TO TALK HER HUSBAND
OUT OF IT.
WOLF?
>> WHAT IS THE BREAKING POINT
FOR THE AUNT AND UNCLE, WHAT
MADE THEM DECIDE TO DEFECT?
>> Reporter: THEY'RE VAGUE ABOUT
THAT IN THE INTERVIEW WITH "THE
WASHINGTON POST."
THE POST ANALYST SAYS IT COULD
BE THE AUNT DECIDED TO DEFECT
WHEN SHE FOUND OUT HER SISTER,
KIM JONG-UN'S MOTHER HAD CANCER.
BECAUSE SHE WAS SO AMBITIOUS
MAIDEN MIDDLE EAST IN THE
REGIME, IF THE MOTHER WASN'T IN
THE